ukrainian forces have dug in deep here
in the steps of southern ukraine between
mikolayev and hereson
and they have russian forces in their
sights
since the ukrainian government launched
its counter-offensive the viking as he
calls himself and his comrades have
ramped up the pressure on the russian
positions
in terms of numbers our artillery can't
measure up to the russians but we top
them in accuracy and speed
they use entire artillery batteries and
spray the area like their grandfathers
did in the second world war
we move two or three pieces into
position shoot in a targeted way and
then pull back
their objective is to take back hereson
a city currently under russian
occupation
anastasia borisova fled from the heisen
area just recently now she's in odessa
aid organizations have collected donated
clothing for the refugees there are some
150 000 of them in the port city
anastasia held out under the occupation
for months till the ever-present fear
became too much for her
along with russian military hardware in
the city with zed markings we suddenly
began seeing equipment with a v symbol
on it that's when we realized that
troops were being redeployed here from
other places
and that there would be a huge battle
and we didn't want to go through that
but the fighting isn't the only thing
that prompted her to flee
her hometown nova kakovka has become a
virtual ghost town she hardly ever
ventured outdoors
whenever they took people away their
relatives would search for them
desperately
some came back
every day more refugees arrive in odessa
from the occupied areas
the journey is a dangerous one but not
only because of the fighting the russian
checkpoints let very few vehicles
through
[Music]
even so volunteers haven't given up
trying to get people out
we met with one of them but we can't
show her face
there are far more troops than before
it feels like there's a checkpoint under
every tree and there are more snipers in
the buildings
we used to be able to move freely around
here
nobody paid attention to us
but now we wouldn't dare to go to the
city center
as it happened anastasia fled just in
time shortly afterwards her apartment
was hit
neighbours sent her photos of it
for now she and her children are trying
to settle back into a semblance of
normalcy but even a door slamming can
bring back memories
[Applause]
[Music]
there tanks are shooting
there are no tanks here
no
no no there were tanks back home there
aren't any here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's quiet at the front lunch time in
the trenches in recent weeks the
ukrainians have been targeting the
russian supply lines
they've been able to destroy several
russian ammunition depots
the effect is that for a time after the
attack the bombardment calms down
but then the russians adapt their
logistics
they learn the lessons our western
rocket launchers and artillery teach
them
unfortunately that means there's no
permanent turn in the tide of the war to
our favor it just evolves
ukraine has succeeded in retaking a few
villages but the offensive is slow going
the viking and his comrades have no idea
how much longer they'll have to remain
here
to carry out a fast aggressive and
active counter offensive we'd need many
more weapons from our partners
especially artillery
without artillery we foot soldiers can't
do all that much
all they can do is wait and remain on
guard
the next attack is only a question of
time
you